[Music]
[Music]
yeah speaking of that tick tocker
killing his lady jesus christ sorry okay
okay yeah let's get dark again to end it
this is [ __ ] crazy this guy that we
we watched this tic-tac-toe yeah
tick-tack tick-tack nice no we didn't
you just said tic-tac yeah yeah yeah
yeah really [ __ ]
cause i'm craving them oh nice
good save we uh talked about this tick
tock on the podcast i think we watched
it he did him mocking skyrim
the sky play that this skyrim guy
killed his wife yep what a [ __ ]
sentence this went this tick tock went
incredibly viral
1.9 million likes on this [ __ ]
you try mercenary work might suit you
hey
watch it
something going on
if you can't for people listening he's
drinking
sewage line
he's just like
he's reenacting being like a player
character like
like running into walls and yeah he's
really good at it this is a funny video
it's like shitty movement it's so
perfect and that's his lady's hand being
the
you know her hand that's her hand jesus
christ bro now she's dead he literally
killed her
so and like confessed to it and
now is pleading guilty or pleading not
guilty yeah close close this
oh sorry i meant like go back to his
profile if you go through some of his
tick tocks you see this dude had lost it
oh really a long time ago keep going he
he sort of like
uh loves doing this tony mont like this
tony montana impression like [ __ ] you
know scarface that's what i was trying
to think of so he meets
manny look at that
scroll up
um
who is this
uh
i think he's like um
uh like an actual person
[Music]
i don't i forget let me look it up maybe
he's what's the movie's based on
i'm an idiot he [ __ ] he's a character
in scarface okay so this guy's clearly
like obsessed with him
yeah so that's stephen bauer excuse me
so he
clearly he's like
this is i mean this is kind of weird
right this whole interaction is so rough
let the audio play on this if we can
you're my hero he says
then he's doing the [ __ ] scarface
impression and then it's the selfie
he's just like
it's like leave him alone dude yeah he's
just like
punishing him with this impression yeah
and then oh
all right close it yes you know you know
that was like the by the third time this
guy like this is a completely different
time in the night and he found him again
it was like with his phone already
opened yo so tell me about like the time
where you and the guy's like dude
[ __ ] leave me alone yeah he like if
you're listening he [ __ ] takes a
selfie video recording
this actor who played a character in
scarface giving him a compliment on his
performance and he's just like geeking
about it and it's such like a
strong-armed i don't know man i think
like he hit a few viral tick tocks and
that [ __ ] just like kind of poisoned him
and he just seems nuts so
seems like he's not right
and
with his lady
she asked for a divorce because they
were married they were together for a
long time
he planted a [ __ ]
like
like a listening device on his child's
ipad yep yep
and he heard
after his wife asked him to move out he
was living in a hotel and he heard her
talking to another man yep
um
yeah
and then he went
to her place and killed them both
and then on the ride home like called
the cops and was like
i just killed my wife and he did the
same thing like to his mom
and see i got arrested obviously he
turned himself in i'm pretty sure didn't
he uh not sure but he pled not guilty
after he picked up his daughter he
called police while driving and they
arrested him 45 minutes later so yeah oh
you just installed the listening app it
wasn't even a device what am i talking
about
oh we're talking over here describing
him like a [ __ ]
like he's double 07 yeah yeah he just
did the creepiest oh weirdest thing
possible yeah pretty [ __ ] crazy bad
energy man yeah it's been out there yeah
no one's even talking about the brian
laundry [ __ ] anymore they found his body
but it was inconclusive how he's dead
yeah
any updates on that i think it was
definitely him
i'm pretty sure
that [ __ ] is ass bro
anyways gucci butt plug what's this all
about gucci's butt plug necklace is here
to make sex toys high fat oh stop it
dude
[ __ ] this is for all the old women that
go see dune yeah
oh [ __ ] bro i saw this hilarious tick
tock of a dude saying in high school
a girl
was wearing a she had a tail
right and he was thinking like
he was thinking it was like one of those
like tails you like clipped to your belt
buckle or something
i forgot what the sequence of events was
but basically like
oh that was that what it was he he
yanked it no he yanked it not knowing
because she like [ __ ] herself or
something yeah oh no he's a teenager and
he yanked oh no he's like dude
it was a butt plunk
he's like
she just [ __ ] just shits herself
just
he's like he's like i remember it like i
pulled it i was just like
why are you wearing a butt plug to
school man
especially especially one with like uh
like an easy like that's like the
easiest thing this is like it's gonna
get caught on something or there's so
many other things besides a teenage
boy's hand that you could get could fall
into bro fall into a door could you
imagine just the door closes too quickly
on your classroom and just [ __ ]
oh my god you [ __ ] sit down and get
changed for pe in the locker room some
girl puts her shoe up as you're getting
up from putting on your
god damn man
can you imagine she was walking out the
house her dad's like the [ __ ] is that
tail can't wear that to school
all over my beautiful shirt
[Laughter]
gucci butt plug necklace dude get out of
here i bet you that thing is like seven
bajillion dollars
bajillion is my new measure of money
you know that [ __ ] is five hundred
dollars they're gonna lay that out next
to a wallet in a glass case
and tourists are gonna go to those
stores and be like yeah i'm thinking
about it yeah
[ __ ] stop dude
i would have more respect for it it was
just a [ __ ]
14-inch dildo
big old dragon dildo just
the one that spits out eggs
industrial chain around the neck so yeah
that's high fashion that's a statement
or a flashlight yeah yeah
you